I signed four years for 26 million that
was like the year that really kicked off
where I am today of the 26 how much
whittles down from that amount where
does it go 13's going to California 37's
going to the feds off the bat 50% and
then my agent's taking 3% some goes to
the union for dues and things like that
at that time where I didn't have any
people helping me work or things like
that you're left with 45% at the end of
it and so that's really where my
entrepreneu start started to kick up and
I started to do the foundation I started
to do my streaming company so I need
needed to start hiring people to help me
and so it just gets chipped down Chi
down chipped down but you can kind of
see me putting myself in a position to
when I'm done playing like I have have
all these Avenues where I can still have
some type of traction in as far as
gaining income and things like that